[Applause]
in that type of environment you know the
crowds really you just come back from
around and all that go on I don't see
the effectiveness of adding to that
chaos by you you screamin and then does
another quorum in there so I tried to be
bit the opposite of that
Diaz fight and the rematch immediately
in the locker room screaming for anyone
did you see what have there's tinier
fights out there why the hell would he
chase fight Floyd okay obviously the
paper but you're going in against
incredible boxer so he's he's lost the
challenges over Conor he can actually
fight pretty much every day in the gym
because he's so rarely hit was for him
to be caught like with just a kind of a
good wrestlers overhand right there
that's pretty much never happens and
then all my time is seen and never seen
even hit your pip-boy give it a shot
like that you always think is there
something I can say because you need up
this kid that's not enough Conor not
just Connor than any kid and you're like
because it's like a debt you know it
just it's gonna take time to got a more
and feel miserable accept that emotion
let her watch truly I want the guy
that's gonna get in the rocky speech
every time he walks in the gym AG but
being freaking exhausting
have you given many of those never know
I've been called the the biggest Conor
McGregor dick Ryder in the past cos I've
defended him sought everyone who had a
corners where's your John Cavanaugh
podcast I thought you were having a
really slide - good job [__] those guys
you did say you called me this morning
you just went john calvin is coming in
my podcast yeah I'm a bit of a fanboy
mid-side china-us yeah everything you've
already been us before okay thanks for
coming on me it's my pleasure to be here
thank you you feeling this morning yeah
just came straight from the airport
so I was supposed to be here for a fight
unfortunately that's off and then I
guess I got tweeted by your Irish boy
send in someone you know that's my
theory
Waterford it's the right beside each
other that's a private joke yeah but
yeah is that what your life site now
just fly in here there and everywhere
this week particularly heavy and for
four nights four cities seven fights all
together and you're cornering these guys
in everything every time yes hope
because for me it's like doing for
podcasts requires research like yes and
you have to be prepared for this to do a
fight is even more intense more intense
than that and you have to be ready game
plan you've prepared all these guys like
how can you possibly be armed like that
many times in a week for that um I tend
to focus on on the fighter rather than
their opponent and just for example so
actually your your Russian colleague
same name cos T and he's fighting
tomorrow night and he's on his
thirteenth opponent so twelve guys are
pulled out in the last two weeks so
people have a huge amount of effort into
guy number one like okay he kind of
moves this way watch for his right hand
okay wrong guy number two no all right
do a bit of research in him okay okay
while we're on five number three four
five six now we're on number thirteen at
this stage and was like just get some an
indication he just needs the few thought
quite a bit
Korea as a coach yeah I have that
started particularly about on now I
think we did see what we're Connor is
some started was like fifty percent of
the time tape only changes in this in
his career and so yeah we're we learned
early on that there's going to be
someone on the other side of the cage
similar way class they can probably
strike and grapple everybody fights and
MMA can do some striking and grappling
so be ready for that
if it's a really big fight yeah you put
a little bit more time into and to see
what their tendencies are like but to be
honest it's it's changes so often as a
stage I'm just like okay what what are
you good what's my guy good that's what
we're gonna focus on they might have
their hopes and dreams their opponent
but that's not really important to me
we've got a good right hand we have a
good double leg we could have taken the
back and joking that's what we're that's
what's gonna happen in the contest so
one thing I notice about you from day
one was how young you are to be a coach
a teacher and you got like people like
Freddie Roach customer or like these
famous coaches of the past and they're
yeah you are
and you you hadn't really had a huge MMA
career yourself and all of a sudden
you're teaching people how do you go
about acquiring that knowledge without
winning a world title yourself right
well in order to deliver that to guys
who want to win will title yeah yeah
well I mean it's a very new sport so it
turned 25 last Monday
so everybody involved I'm kind of I'm an
old guy could parole view so yeah yeah
and and and the great thing about the
sport as well is it's still being
figured out what's the best way of doing
things I remember when when remember
that famous when Machida like dude Krane
kicked Randy Couture I mean if a couple
years ago of you to set a karate guy
will knock a really good wrestler with a
crane kick your I'm a huge Machida fun
oh yeah so like obviously I started but
a lot of people did Rodney kachou 18
Ortiz and then when Machida came on and
like I was a karate kid fun when I write
I was like daniel larusso's here yes
he's in the yeah yeah and he turns up
and he can't be touched he can't be here
and it really even Rogen was like
welcome to the Machida era yeah like we
all fought remember styling yeah
hit without being hit and it's like a
variation on boxing and yeah it just
seemed to common cycles or like we had
the dominance of a wrestler
just feel like with call me a khabib and
a lot of good wrestlers out there that's
coming back now just right and yeah but
it's it's it's it's coming back with
add-ons you know like there it it if you
look at Habib you know a stand-up had
improved hugely and in his in his fight
corner if you go back two or three
fights um so yeah it's just it's
evolving all the time and just being
good at one thing or even being good at
two things is not and he is not good
enough anymore if you want to get to
that very elite level so it's it's one
of the things I do love about the sport
is that you're constantly even my my guy
Lee Hammond actually he's fighting right
now I guess and is fighting Friday at
the IMF and World title in Bahrain and
in his first fight in the tournament
this week he'd hit a submission that's
never been done before and you know the
sports the data land if I wanted first
off Hamill plateau were calling is in
this film is Hammond it's variation of
an omoplata and I had an arm strangle so
um I actually my girlfriend I gave her
she a toilet or the name to the Hama
Plata and then it got stolen like I
still most of her stuff um so yeah
included are clothes of course yeah by
Monster Energy and so it's one of the
things that's a real attraction for me
for MMA is that you can't you can't rest
on your laurels you can't be like okay
we got to figure it out now so this is
what you do and then some kid comes
along and does something completely
different you let go okay now we gotta
watch out for that yeah always gone how
do you do that because I was find it
interesting when you hear athletes and
all these different sports interviewed
if you football and basketball
basketball guys very often now are
talking about I'll pick one thing and
I'll add that to my game is that a
similar approach with a fight well you
look at a fight and go right let's try
and add something to your to you before
your fight or what can you add three
things at a time can you have many
different things can you work on it once
with one fighter yeah it's a good
question am so if you've got your
training to learn period and many of
your fighting to win period and you've
got it
so that that's why if a fighter is kind
of not really in the gym much and then
you just comes in for a six-week fight
camp not gonna go too far because during
the six weeks you're fighting to win so
you kind of polishing what you're
already very good at because look we're
we're
to kick the legs off this guy Oregon or
wrestling whatever we're gonna do so
let's just find you that game plan
you're not gonna win at 4-6 weeks I
would say okay let's let's add on boxing
which you've which you're not really
good at yeah that has to happen outside
of that six or eight week period that's
that's your training training to learn
period and that's where you got to see
if someone's gonna really go with this
sport because they're doing it because
it's enjoyable yeah you must enjoy
something if you're gonna be good at it
because you're gonna have to do it for
about 10 years before you're any sort of
decent skill level um so it's a little
bit on them it's a little bit on the
fighter that's that's where they have to
accept personal responsibility I have a
busy fight team I'm not gonna I'm not
the type of coach that's like where's
that where's Dave today and then I'm in
the office calling him if he's in he
gets my attention if he's not he doesn't
um so yeah it's it's a little bit under
on the fighter and then they've got to
be when their fights over when the
contest is over back in the gym okay
let's analyze what we did there what we
did well what we what we need to work on
and okay you're you I've never seen you
really go for takedowns let's let's
spend the four six week or tremont
period working your single legs that's
how it actually sounds quite enjoyable
like sort of looking at something that
has to be yeah it has to be if it's if
it's not enjoyable then you won't do it
enough I can I'm actually putting
together I'm doing a talk next week
about motivation and it's a little bit
of talking about that that the idea of
motivation is kind of nonsensical
because I could motivate you to do
something short-term and you know I'm a
rocky montage and get you fired up but
tomorrow then you're gonna have to find
something that's it's going to be
something else other than like a cool
lady song that got you moving you're
gonna have to enjoy it and because
anything worth doing you know being a
really good musician or a good fighter
or a good artist or in a successful
business it's gonna be daily effort for
10 years it doesn't seem to be avoidable
you know even Leehom and I'll just have
looking back over so many of my fighters
Lee Hammonds would be 10 years this year
and he's fighting for his world title
you know if Connor was there would be 10
years he fought for his first world
title
that's a logic number seems to be tensed
10,000 hours kind of yeah yeah seems to
somewhere fall in that now you get the
odd freak you know Gunnar Nelson was a
competitive black belt after less than
four years training I really disliked
that guy because I was million I was
twelve years trying to get any sort of
decent level and but you know there's
always gonna be a belarius but if you
look at the bell curve the meat the meat
of the population if you're sitting down
you're saying right I'm gonna get really
good at guitar you know that could be
able to play get her to a very high
level and right get ready for daily
effort for ten years mhm then you're
gonna be we're talking about so from the
teachers perspective like what is it
that drew you to that then is the reason
why you wanted to go into that yeah so
um I was always a teacher III I love
teaching anything I taught my mother had
to use our computer and and when I was
in university I was studying engineering
and maths and am like when it came close
to graduating I was thinking what they
want to do I came close to moving to
Boston I was down to the last two for a
job with Boston Scientific which would
have meant moving to Boston and I would
never really don't have an A or any that
world Wow um that's problem-solving as
well though weirdly which kind of is
jujitsu I guess yeah yeah hundred
percent I wonder worse and there because
I I sometimes like it annoys me that I
put five years is five years into being
an engineer like I wish I had it on
sports science or business or
accountancy something that would have
been useful for what I do now but and
you could have charged Cara
double yeah alright man I'm your [__]
the Cubbies yes so when I graduated I
decided am well that's a opened my first
gym but I was I was in between going
back and doing an H did to become a
maths teacher I I just I just really
love teaching I love I look at that
moment where you see someone's eyes kind
of you know kind of go oh yeah you know
you get that realization and I said yeah
Thrones believe that does it like this
in I guess when you want to be world
champion there's a shelf life for when
you're either gonna do or you're not but
you you could do this to the old mr.
Miyagi it could be that guy who's 65 and
still fulfilled by this I hope so I had
that image of me being like you know
Mickey and rocky do you think you'll go
that you'll think you'll go the whole
way I I could never see myself not being
involved at some level maybe the
high-end professional and I think that
has a shelf life because it's it's very
stressful and there's a huge amount to
travel and it's okay it's wearing um but
you know I just came from the amateur I
was briefly at the amateur World
Championships there in Bahrain and I
love that atmosphere really it's I could
see myself going to more towards that as
time goes on but sitting at home and
just staring at the walls no III v8
tuned to go down the gym and hear about
this new kid that's that's doing so it's
doing really well on the Sarah Kay let's
let's have a look at him how does he
move and at this point you must have
your pick of tongue especially in
Ireland I would guess is there a way you
sort of go through things in your mind
when you're looking at new talent coming
through how you decide who gets your
time and whoever shows up you know
whoever shows up and it's I have a MMA
team session every day 1 o'clock and
always pretty busy but there still is
the few night there still is a few
phases that are just there all the time
and then you've got the Drifters and
I've got guys coming to fight camps and
but does that person that's just there
consistently day and a day and a oh I
did interview with wit with Joe wicks
and I was talking about again about this
10,000 air thing and stick-to-itiveness
that's really what it comes down to you
know you say well how quickly can you
tell if somebody's going to be high
level of fighting and there's definitely
some early indicators but one thing I
can't answer is is he gonna be here in a
year you know it's just as easy on our
elbows for these three months now and
just just going at it you know and you
see he's good strike in his restaurants
coming on he's in phenomenal shape but
maybe a little bit of injury prone or
maybe he gets a new girlfriend there he
finds you know you just eat just drifts
just that guy that's just
stick-to-itiveness that's just gonna be
doing the daily grind self as we call it
has to be self-motivated because he has
to enjoy it I won't I'm not the guy
that's gonna give me the rocky speech
every time he walks in the gym like
that'd be a frickin exhausting
have you given many of those never never
actually quite a calm guy like even
between rounds I you see some corner
screaming that yeah I even in the Kabir
fight I remember he had two guys
screaming out a boy and you're just like
this is what we work for like you and
you're very simple messages straight
yeah well if you can imagine what must
be going on yeah I have I fought a few
times I put in that type of environment
you know crowd scream and then you just
come back from around and all that go on
I don't see the the effectiveness of
adding to that chaos my you you
screaming and then there's another
corner man there so I try to be that the
opposite of that and am i usually have
what I'm gonna say ready about 30
seconds before the round is over
mmm-hmm one positive and damn one thing
to watch over and then that's it because
that's all you can retain and that well
what are you gonna say you know you see
guys in for 60 seconds under demonstrate
amuse and getting on the floor wait
watch this video and they even see that
like a warm-up rooms fighters you know
the coach is teaching him a technique
I'm like read you know teach them
something new under war we're making the
luck what you were saying before about
how there's this time to learn and then
this time to shop in those tools and
when Eddie Alvarez was saying no we're
changing our pads we're doing this we're
learning this and you're like dude like
yeah yeah yeah exactly you know even
even when I see safe fighters and you
know the polio fight we could an injury
it's just happened one of my one of my
guys recently as well and you think well
what we doing fight week that was that
strenuous we aspiring at that stage then
we call that anxiety training that's
that's because you think all five days
time is it's almost like cramming for an
exam which we all did and it what kind
of works for for memory it works for
short-term you can't actually crime
quite well for for exams but you can't
do that for a skill you know you imagine
imagine you were suddenly going to be
playing on Wembley Arena
again I'll go back to playing the piano
or something like that and you're like
okay let her do you know if you're not
gonna learn anything at this stage and
we're fighting even more so so our last
two weeks is is usually pretty pretty
soft training and it's very hard you're
in your twenties you're you know you're
thinking about this [__] you're
gonna be fighting you know the crowds
gonna be there it's very hard to hold
the guy back at that stage it must be
really hard with Conor especially
because when we see him in the press
conference in the wind I mean he's the
most animated fighter of all time and
they of seein yeah but he has a switch
you know he's a he's a professional he
he more than most understands that
two-week period and I've been able to
hold him back you know the Serena's in
his his younger days when he was you
know in his late teens and early
twenties yeah just wanted to fight every
day was just like when you first met him
and stuff what was that like um you know
III was kind of joke saying this that
you know you walked in the gym and the
Clarets open and the Thunder ball came
down but it's just another guy there's
another guy walking in the gym and a few
teens early on if that were good
indicators was that he was exceptionally
you could hit exceptionally hard and
that doesn't I'm very I'm really
struggling to find the formula for that
I really don't have to say that it's
magic but his body looks different that
tough for me that's my main thing is he
has really long arms and really broad
shoulders but he's not a very big guy in
terms of height yes odd shape yeah and
heavy hitters do seem to and then you
put then you look at Tyson and use small
squat guy so it's you know it's
technical genetic and then seems to be
some to do levers as well and length of
limbs yeah for us a hobby was saying
about lengths of distance of muscle
tissue where they connect and all this
right and I'm just like dude it's all
too complicated like yes nor the chin
[__] seems to shut up right so so
yeah and I'm kind of like that as well I
just kind of like to know what the
results are and it was also a very hard
I so Paul so you're already know that's
gonna be awkward for for his opponents
very witty very funny very confident
that confidence was always there even
when
yeah I'm a bit of something I read about
that on you and your book you beach in
them denier bit yeah that's that that's
it's not not quite like that and not on
the feet
but you took them down and sort of yeah
yeah was yeah yeah I'm a million years
ago and I don't want this getting cliff
top by the way offers Okada McGregor for
the next UFC fight yeah yeah yeah I'm
glad we're friends now because he could
certainly do a whole lot worse to me now
but yeah I remember like one of our
early training sessions you know he when
he came to me who's already decent
decent boxer but he had no grappling no
no no wrestling at all and we're doing a
drill and I took him down but he
wouldn't stop and I was like seaming
your back hit the mat that was the end
of it he goes alright
fast forward about six weeks or eight
weeks we're doing the drill again and I
end up on my back and he go Steven your
back hit the mat so we had that room
rapport very early on and his
obsessiveness with technique as well
that was unusual I still haven't really
seen that since just constantly message
me all about this all about that all
about this his remains will seem to
never show off never he says he can't
watch a movie because you know it's too
long to not be thinking about this yeah
you know he's gonna have for sure he's
like drifting thinking about two
gorillas headlock and each other and
there's this attention span just crop
generally like in terms of other stuff
like interests to talk about oh this
won't you can't get him to it but his
attention I think doesn't it doesn't
have to he's got that fu money as you
say um but then if it's see if you're
talking about a topic of interest
whether that's business or fighting yes
here you're gonna have his full
attention was there a moment back then
where you were like oh this guy is the
the guy who's gonna take this gym to the
next level in terms of SPG's just global
awareness or was there a moment and you
know like a kind of Gunnar Nelson broke
before Conor you know he had a couple of
big wins in the UFC and I was I actually
moved to Iceland I was I packed up and
gone and
I last the best six months there was
very dark very cold I just was kind of
dumb with Dublin you know I wanted to
try something new
Connor just didn't see to be eight to
get a break the gym I was always just
broke Jim was never making any money and
I just I got I got a little bit
disillusioned now and I felt a little
Iceland when I went for a weekend every
now and then then I actually packed up
and moved there and it was a late summer
and I got it past the first winter and
then I was like oh god no home and then
a couple of things just happened quickly
together and one of them was from
getting the offer he got it finally
Shaun Shelby after years of bullying on
replied to my email and we got it I
won't say late no it wasn't late that
was at all we got for four months
notices is debuting in Sweden and I
thought okay if I can keep this guy on
the straight and narrow for these next
few months and because he was even I
felt starting to drift a little bit you
know cuz he'd put so much into and again
he was just again that that 10 year
broke entrepreneurial story where just
everyday just I'm sure you I'm sure you
have a story kick getting there in this
beautiful London apartment but we even
start here right just given this day one
and just days we go mama doom like
what's the point of this list
it's that obsession for me personally of
like always trying and like having
moments like this is a formation of like
alright I'm doing the right right thing
yeah right I mean I'm getting people I
respect than the Shone's
right but yeah so we got that contract
and then that was that oak that was
another boost and I just felt if I can
get him in front of Dana in front of the
cameras and he fights the way fight and
then we ended up getting matched against
a friend of mine well his gym is not her
SPG so I give all the freaking guys we
could a guy Marcus and he's a good
fighter yet he put up what I knew but I
knew what would happen right
we all knew anyone that follows Connor
knew knew what was going to happen the
angles he was coming in from and that
first fight were it was gorgeous
it's a gorgeous fire sale like watching
her back and Kenny Florian called it's
all faithfully Kenny air yeah
hee hee give us a nice share there we
got some good sound bites out loud and
then of course the 60 G's baby that was
the beginning I was there little buddy
how did very I think Dana just seen the
dollar signs very very quickly with with
Connor oh yeah well you can imagine as a
promoter you look at this guy and he's
you know he's he's Irish again he's
witty he's Jeremy's loud and he can
fight like hell it's not like he was
just a good talker and then fighting was
you know great fighter great talker
they don't come along very often one
thing I feel like hasn't been really
appreciated from the rest of Mme well
the ones who don't like Connor is he he
didn't have it easy at all and a lot of
people felt like they were favorable
matchups but then when you look at how
good Dustin Poirier is being post the
McGregor fighting and others like Eddie
Alvarez and he really had a hard run in
my opinion the one fight I always think
was like the defining moment looking
back at that period of time was the Chad
Mendes fight it just seemed like
everything was against you guys the
injury the pole out and it all been
building up this title fight
what was that night like in particular
ended with you on the cage with him yeah
that was one of those affirmation
moments just just really really special
you know that was I think is by this
tent here Whitney started with me 16 17
and I guess that's three or four years
ago now and words fail you know it's
much cry in heaven to that fight like I
think that's when and then looking back
at it we've never seen anything like
emotional from him anywhere near that
like that that's when you know how much
it meant to him how did you feel when he
was on the bottom in the second row and
particularly in its you know everyone
said that this is what would happen yeah
yeah not that stressed you know it's 25
minutes we when we knew we had 25
minutes in there no I just wasn't really
concerned yet you know if we had have
come back in a bad way from the end of
that round and you go out round free and
he's immediate ache now as well you're
like well okay no no we know we're
looking at a scenario where he's dated
down three rounds he's got
but at that stage okay you know Mendes
have slowed him down a little bit he
wasn't wasn't massive amounts of damage
and he was kind of complaining to her
when when Connor was hitting him so you
can see frustrating list was was was
kicking in and and a big big part of as
well as just how much Connor was
enjoying it so it's infectious you know
it's one of my favorite images actually
where he walks out for round two and
he's smiling he's going like this and
he's got a card and what if I taught
does that there's something it does to
the other fighter I remember Brock
Lesnar smiling at Shane Carwin right for
the second round after Shane Carwin had
wailed on him for about five minutes
right that's not what you want to see
someone's [__] smile that's not ideal
no no I wouldn't be founded now that was
that was like a real moment for me
because it felt like if he wins this
then then he's the real deal but I
believed he was gonna win it but it
seemed that the whole MMA world was just
not fully convinced yet Kazuki he could
talk he could knock people out but the
Chad Mendes was on a higher level than
anyone he'd fought and I loved the
technique he is because it's there's a
few like highlight reels and I call up
the heartbreaker so I had it I have a
pretty good guillotine choke and damn
anytime I roll the corner and you know
as his levels getting better and better
and better it got to Sage where I was
very rarely able to catch him but I
could get in with the odd guillotine
choke until this came along that he was
eight does this kind of crocodile roll
mhm
which couldn't Nelson actually come up
with well I'm sure it's what people
don't as well love's first time I seen
and then I showed it to Conor I don't
know why I did because then my only
chance of getting in was gonna so I used
to call it the heartbreaker cuz I would
just about having meaningful he'd spin
out and he be on top of me and I cut
down and there was a you know there was
a little clip of his training just a
couple of weeks in the lead-up to the
Mendes fighting were going over that and
then he does within the fight and the
camera switches to me and you see like
this figure here and he this time sorry
that was his signature move as well like
mend and you sear organs like all these
curtains
yeah okay now smell very good guillotine
you look at the shape of Mendez you can
imagine the squeeze you would have very
good at a very good at a choke but Conor
is very good at getting out of it
I think he's under rated as well kind of
for that specifically like touching him
like in terms of like yeah he's been
submitted before but generally I think
it's not like a glaring weakness like at
all I think his ground games a lot
better than what people give him credit
for unjust takedown defense I was seeing
in the Kabir fight like even Daniel
Cormier came out who basically trains
with could be was like the Gregor did
everything right pretty much it's just
yeah computers very good oh yeah yeah
yeah that always I always find
interesting is you know the the higher
level you get you know the more likely
you are to find someone who's got
something that you've never come up
against before that you you know they've
got the ultimate strength that kind of
might not be able to come out again how
do you train someone for that because
your guillotine isn't gonna be the same
as someone who you know is maybe the
best in the world at that or something
how do you train someone for that and
prepare them for possibly the best
version of whatever they're coming up
against sure to flip it around I always
want to help people prepare for Conor
like hey yeah where you gonna get this
so Paul and I just hit so hard and and
it just comes down to look you've got to
do your best you've got it you've got to
bring guys that have similar looks um
are you gonna prepare for Floyd
Mayweather you know the greatest
defensive boxer of all time you do your
best so IIIi don't need to Sonny or
nobody has figured out any way any exact
magical formula we tried to look at our
tendencies we tried to create scenarios
to replicate them we tried to get
sparring partners to replicate their
movements and then you do your best
he's winning he always just strikes me
you must get into the ring or someone
must get into the ring at some point and
sort of thing I've never been hit that
hard before this is the hardest I've
ever been hit and he's up but you're
looking at Conor McGregor and he's just
going yeah I hit pretty hard
yeah some opponents I've kind of
admitted that that the first one is sort
of yeah jarring you know you didn't know
like yeah kind of kind of your vision
blows a little yeah yeah yeah I thought
I felt like with the Alvarez fight in
particular there was a look on his face
and al Burris is a hard hard man yes but
there was a what the [__] moment yes he
was lying on the floor like yeah
you for a bus that because I'm a father
but he Alvarez me too Dom have you ever
said to Connor just hit me as hard as
you can sort of a Tyler didn't start
don't think you would do that no I'm
just like that's not my thing
God just hit me as hard as you can well
masochistic Gordon yeah yeah moving on
from not the Aldo fight
I felt like personally that was when we
we've seen a superstar born because and
what really annoyed me from a fan of
Magura cause I kind of just took a
liking because he's a [__] talker and I
like [__] Torres and his movement is was
so unusual but when he did that and he
predicted it as well first exchange this
is what's going to happen you see the
pictures backstage like it wasn't just
like talking he really believed that
this was going to happen very quickly
everyone calls Aldo the pound-for-pound
number one they introduced him as that
which or org and calls him that everyone
is accepting of that Conor McGregor wins
no one calls in pound-for-pound of war
at all
he stood just when he smoked him and it
was like as a little punch like it was
that a little bit for you being team
McGregor frustrating still cuz you're
like what do we have to do absolutely
predictable you know absolutely
predictable and so because of that I
just don't let it let it bother me he's
very well-paid he's won some great
fights he's got a couple of championship
belts that that's more than enough and
we get look yeah we get we get it some
ribbing online but we get a huge amount
of support as well you're a good self
and thank you
you know we get is so much support so
you can kind of I guess you can choose
to sort of read five comments or you can
choose to Rico comments and I used to go
to them all and be kind of per what's
the point it's it's not gonna it's not
gonna make you feel any better at the
end of the day so I tend to I'm very
lucky I've got just kind of a very super
low level of celebrity in Dublin that
pretty much to stuff with people saying
you're doing a great job thank you or
you know I liked your book or you know
Conor speeches would give me a little
bit of inspiration that's the level I
receive and that's
world I choose to stay in and live in
and it's it's it's mostly positive so
yeah and I do want to talk about like a
lot you know the fighters and stuff like
that I don't mean it just kind of Conor
kind of kind of but obviously this is
sort of something I've wanted to ask you
for a to understand so for me as a fan
of Conor when he fought near that was
obviously supposed to be the lightweight
fight it got cancelled and then next
thing you know he's fighting a [__]
well that way
huge Nate Diaz but it did feel like
knocking Jersey Iowa was easy and as
quickly as he did was probably the worst
thing that ever happened to Connors
fight career in my opinion from a farm
because he he looked so [__]
confident in that knee if i warping in
like i'm just gonna [__] tear through
this guy and when you watch that first
round he isn't picking his shots
anywhere near as carefully and he's
being very wild and just expecting him
to go and although he underestimated me
and everyone did i think we've heard
nature of what a fighter he is in that
fight but uh was that we've seen the
documentary we see how quiet it is and
not go room afterwards was that one of
the most humbling moments of the career
v you guys as a team yeah i mean every
losses you know miserable on the day you
know there's there's no I try I've done
I think close to a thousand fights maybe
at this stage and well you know plenty
of losses in there and you always think
is there something they can say because
you know you got this kid that's not
knock honor not just Connor but any kid
and you're like no it's it cuz it's like
a debt you know at this it's gonna take
time to gotta mourn there's no there's
no point in trying to skip that don't
you worry about that you're gonna get it
next time
no feel miserable accept that emotion
let it wash true you and it'll pass and
a couple of errors you know or a day or
two at most I say I usually lock myself
in a dark room need a lot of chocolate
for a day but then you get it step out
the room yeah I could say after the
computer fight you will put you wounded
on the broadcast yeah upset almost a
little bit I could say that oh yeah of
course of course I'm not a robot and I'm
not gonna pretend that they didn't hear
me a lot of course I still have moments
where a year if we do this why do we do
that but you can't live in that world
and I certainly don't because you know
we've great wins and I don't spend
months did you see that you know because
that's not me I'm the next weekend with
another kid on another show and you've
just got to get ready ready for that and
Connors always being a I think really
good at handling
losses because you know III think the
job the role of a coach early on with a
fighter in any sport to be to be honest
is to create an environment where it's
safe to have lots of little failures
have loads of little failures every day
had little failures in your gym little
losses in jiu-jitsu it's very apparent
because if the top out that's a loss you
know and boxing you get hit and rest and
you get a takedown and get comfortable
with that and understand actually we
don't have lots of little failures
you're never gonna improve I have some
guys that when they join my fight team
you know maybe they've come from a
smaller team or your skill level isn't
quite there yet and they're just getting
you know they never have any real
success every time you try something
they lose and it can make them really
down and say well the only thing worse
than losing all the time in the gym will
be winning all the time in the gym if
you're in if you're in an environment in
your gym where failure and losses is not
part of your daily routine you should
probably look at trying to expand or
trying to bring in someone who can do
that you so if early on before the the
bright lights are shining you're in a
you're comfortable with those multiple
failures and losses and you see what
they actually do for you and that they
make you improve fast forward a decade
and you learn you can handle major
traumatic losses and failures and you
know what to do you know to hold your
head up
everybody has stumbles and accept it see
what went wrong improve it and it's one
of my favourite stories that that lost
today and then the forum on training and
then coming back into win I'll you know
I get asked to go to schools and give
talks in stuff like I talk a lot about
that and that journey and and you know
he could have he could have ran the
other way
he could have pointed the finger and
blaming people but no took it on the
chin made the adjustments went back in
and then you know it was a nice
fairytale ending that we that we want
it's all your whole ethos is we're not
learners and right so that breathes life
in the best-selling book and we'll put
that makes a great stocking seller in
its engine though because I listen to is
actually a Conan O'Brien podcast
yesterday and he was saying some people
learn the wrong things from a win some
people learn the wrong things from a
loss and it's about finding the right
thing to learn
have you picked that up along because
some obviously when you have a win that
feeling you almost want leave it all
behind we won we did it all right but
that's not always the case is it yeah
you know it's it's hard getting it to
the top it's a lot tougher staying at
the time yeah so yeah you've got to try
and maintain that beginner attitude and
then and always be trying to improve
yourself and learn it's not easy and
that's just a constant kind of battle
that you have with yourself and but yeah
if you don't you'll be passed by how do
you get a fighter or you know something
someone who is a Conor McGregor someone
who's such a big personality someone who
may be publicly acts you know they've
got everything worked out how privately
do you cultivate a mentality where you
are learning with him mm-hmm
again like you know the training
environment you know Connor is loves
going against guys who are better than
him
you know like Dylan Dallas is higher
level jujitsu don't think Connor that's
just a fact and he will tap Connor a bit
winter rolling and he keeps jumping in
there he doesn't want to go at some guy
that's not an ego to him like why the
hell would he chase fight and Floyd okay
obviously was a good payday but you're
going in against incredible boxer you
chased a heavy fight after two years
outside a cage I told you I wouldn't
want to do that so he's he's loves the
challenges he loves going in against
guys and who he loves training in those
type of environments where he is gonna
have small failures and sit back and say
what why you know I think especially for
Conor he gets frustrated he actually
look at kind of pissed off of his
partners are not putting it on them he
really wants to feel that pressure so
it's not really something that I have to
put a huge amount of effort in it kind
of just happens
you know with this young lad you've got
Gallagher yes who showed a lot of talent
and got he got knocked out recently in
Bellator what was it like talking to him
after that did you take some of those
lessons that you've learned with Connor
and use them in bringing him buckle and
that's you know I'm very lucky that I
have such a strong person like that in
the gym that the likes of Gallaher has
seen what he did after you know he's had
a couple of losses you know Duffy loss
hidden accosted obviously the Nate loss
and so II kind of have to scope.c memory
did yeah you don't have to go true at
all again but but God I heard is you
know I think he was 20 or something when
that happened and but he's got an old
head and young shoulders and you see the
deal with it really well mentally
fantastic you know and he was seven and
now going into that and it is you know
they're getting really that always as
always as always a tough one and as a
coach you're always kind of like well
what will what will he do with this I
how do you go into and you know have a
kind of a diva fit and just leave or
already going it you never quite know
because it's is abuse I figured what way
you would go you know have you out being
blamed from that from the fight above
had an argument or whatever no no I
haven't no thankfully you know and
that's the relationship you build with
them where it's not about that dynamic
yeah yeah yeah I think as well like if
you Jenny when you put everything into
the contest if you prepare it as best
you can you go in there and you have a
good fight I don't it lost it's not as
dramatic you know you can now better guy
one of the line well what are you gonna
do if you've got well paid and
relatively injury free and we can be
back in the gym next week we can't
really ask for a huge amount more than
that I'm with collar
yeah he came backstage and he kicked
chairs around and have a little
breakdown that absolutely normal and
then the next day you smile and like huh
alright here we go
you know that's what I do wrong give me
give me to break down what am I gonna do
how am I gonna improve on that you know
like when Gallagher was fifteen he moved
down from the north of Ireland he moved
down the live with me drop the whole
school and lived with me for a couple
years so we would have daily
conversations you know we would come
back from the gym and just be chatting
into the night so I
I probably had more contact with him and
pretty much animal fighters because we
just had that relationship kind of big
brudder relationship so I wasn't
surprised how he reacted to it sorry am
i cool I'm always interested in the
dynamic between you know someone who is
because essentially you're you're a
partner but you're also someone who's
teaching them something you're someone
who's trying to take them on a journey
and sometimes you know the classic
narrative is that you know the the
mentor becomes the guy learns in the end
all those you know the dynamics always
changing between the person who's
teaching and the person who's being
taught right how do you is do you try
and cultivate the same dynamic with
every fighter or are you tailor making
that to each fighter because to me that
strikes me is a really hard thing and a
lot of teachers go through that they
have to find the right way to teach yeah
yeah and and that relationship just
takes time you know there's there's no
way to Russia we do get a lot of
inquiries from fighters and them you
know the training somewhere else and
they're like they have a big fight in
two weeks time the message can I come in
and prepare for fighting like no yeah
what am I gonna do in two weeks it's not
some secret magic move that we have that
the others don't and then that goes for
any gym it's it's time in and a
relationship between a fight owner coach
takes a long time to build that level of
trust and I don't see any way of like
just actually when I was in tel-aviv a
couple of nights ago my guy was calling
the technique he's caught the choke he
was like he was about to tap he put his
hand up to tap and the way he was
positioned he could actually catch my
eye so I was able to like physically
show him what to do but that took a lot
of trust for him to do what I was
telling him because he was going
unconscious and tank Wow oh yeah
thankfully it worked out he escaped and
he went on to win the fight and I
drifted there what the hell is the
question building that relationship and
sort of and because it I guess what I
was trying to get is how adaptable you
are as a yes yeah yeah yeah so I do
think it's a coach's job to adapt you
know because the the fighters are gonna
have different personalities and
different needs and so my drill sergeant
wait and need that so um I'm more
passive and just create an environment
for them to be able to figure things out
themselves
yeah you you you have to just put it in
that time and you've got to hang out
with them you've got to see what they
like to read what to TV they like you
know it's like I said there's no quick
formula it's it's time get to know them
get to know the personality experience
different scenarios with them and then
you sort of thing okay one trick I have
actually is that I try to get all of my
fighters to corner with me for at least
one fight because Dan I can usually see
what they want right so if I see Dan
backstage and they're getting the guy
motivated come honest you know you don't
smash this guy there's no way I'm kind
of looking at him going ah so he likes
that yeah maybe he maybe they're super
quiet backstage okay he probably just
likes quietness yeah you know so that's
that's one little thing I have one
little sort of trick almost I have to
see isn't it yeah it's like doing you
see corner in the way that they want to
be cornered yeah which is really
interesting I mean I guess we have a
similar relationship in that sense like
well like a bit I think me and you I
like Kidman Connor yeah I thought make
solutions which he's the company all
right yeah sure because we with the way
we were sort of thrown into the fire
when we went away we went on a football
trip three really intense days and I had
no idea how to direct Brian I know at
that time I was type myself around as a
director and I was I had no idea how to
direct you so I was going let's just get
into this scene and you were like what
are we doing I was like come on we're
not we're doing and now having been
directed by you and having directed you
more we have a much better working
relationship and I think we trust each
other a lot more trust yeah and Trust
takes time
and you can't claim to trust somebody
after a day yeah exactly you're lying
yeah or crazy both but I find that so
fascinating as well especially with
you've written a book on it like do you
[Music]
for me what I'm trying to get at is that
like how much of the psychology are you
thinking right I need to do this in
order for him to react like this and
then we're gonna get to this stage or is
it more intuitive as a process for you
and do you want them to know that
process or do you want them to be
completely oblivious to it cuz that's a
tricky way of balance yeah I think I
know your question like and there is
times where I know that if I tell
someone to do something they probably
won't yeah but if I can make it make
them think it's their idea then d well
Oh funny that story about this no go
where should we get a nice new flat at
the top of a tower block few days later
Lawrence I was think we should get a
nice new family stop with the public
that's great idea Brian I'm pretty sure
you don't have to have those chests with
Connor it's a good spender yeah yeah
which like looking moving on throughout
his fight career yeah well you had the
mirror the fight which to me was just
like it was what it was
do you know what I mean like it would
have been great if he'd win it and so
actually when I look back at that I
think to myself like because you have
your what-ifs as a fan of a football
team or if I or whatever and I think
myself what if he'd hung back at the
start and sort of was just like well
you're the boxer come on then beat me up
you know and instead of having the
quality in put it put it on because
Connors a comment upon sure and if he
when he did land it was a counter punch
that land on me have you thought about
that as well of course of course and he
does Milanese we reassessment more or
less and I I have no interest in in
going into boxing it was a one-off and
it's just not the sport for me I love
mixed martial arts have huge amount of
time and respect for him but I was
baiting I took away from it that the the
the boxing game seems to be there's
almost like triack's in the 12-round
fight you get the first four rounds it's
almost like a feeling out process the
middle four rounds seems to determine
who's gonna win or lose and then the
final four rounds which is usually does
finale you know it and we were a huge
went into the first four rounds which
you know I think I think in the frame
rail one I don't think Mayweather even
threw a punch in electron one and you
compare that with Conor to it so he's a
wily veteran it was it was a pleasure to
and to be a part of it and to see you
know with this where's he from Japan
this kid attention Nakamura I think
right
that's back on know what's back on yeah
I seen that yeah I don't know what is it
just pure boxing or sir it will be boxed
in just pure don't get that
anyone kicking him in this lifetime does
he get pay for the press conferences
because this would be a really genius
way for my son fights off fights on file
press conferences later you're a
millionaire no he said he's already he's
been paid like ten million just for the
press conference or some [__] like well
I can call the fight off and on if it's
always going on
as a bit embarrassing for I guess for me
with McGregor there was there was a
funny one I had it a guy messaged me
just a few days ago and then Chinese
kickboxer wants to do wanted to do tree
rounds a corner for five million Wow he
said he was gonna put it in escrow like
it wasn't like useless because they get
a million messages like that today they
just don't pay attention but this guy
was connected and it was you know who
was legitimate offer but I know you
wouldn't you must get so many like say
you must get yeah tell him I know you
tuber he'll turn up yeah yeah it does to
get yelled the old funny message like
that and like I said it was a January
and I know the boxing promoter well and
he's very well known so he wasn't gonna
come was an offer that wasn't legitimate
it's funny cuz there's a Chinese guy who
wants to fight you for 20 quid in the
back alley so yeah we had that we had
that moment and it was it was iconic and
that but coming back in to khabib I've
watched there could be a fight a few
times now and I really feel like he
could have won that fight even even
though he had two years off I felt like
when Rogan told you about really was
itis you really deserve a rematch after
I was so dominant and when I look back
and I was like not reaiiy didn't think
was that dominant of a fight at all but
like but in the moment you get carried
away with the emotions these two Titans
are gone head had it it feels that way
but correct as if you think I'm wrong
but I felt like round one was not really
a lot happening round two could be I
feel like it's fair to save gotten lucky
with that punch because in 99 faiths I
don't think could be will meet that
again like that overhand right and and
that really gave him the round but even
still after that the worst round that
Connor had probably had in the UFC he
still won the third round
and obviously he got the takedown on the
fourth but do you now looking back to
that feel an immediate rematch is like
the way forward for Conor and first part
first and so yeah the fight
I don't massively disagree or anything
he said there I don't think it was a
lucky punch I think if you try a punch
you mean it's a land and a landed and so
you know credit where it's due and but
yeah that that was it was a it was a
shock you know here I hadn't really seen
that kind of style of self a moment
where he's not
that's not could be again I know I know
what you're saying mm-hmm I also know
about Twitter he'll go first yeah and
pecan are so hard to hit in the gym
thank you just very rarity like I mean
you're training fighters it's it's it's
it's tough okay so the best training for
fighters is fighting now the problem
with that is is that it's higher than
your body so you can't just fight all
all day every day because you taken
punishment but it would be the ideal way
to train because it gets you a very
skillful very fast so we have to come up
with games to sort of mimic that ba ba
ba ba but what Carter he can actually
fight pretty much every day in the gym
because he's so rarely hit so that's
what I think this is actually why he got
so good and so fast but for him to be
caught like with just a kind of a with
wrestlers overhand right there that's
pretty much never happens and then all
my time I see him never seen him in hit
but people hit with a shot like that and
and yet but if you again even in the
fight half a second later he spun him on
defense and he landed his own knee and
he actually got up at the end of the
second round back to his feet from a
takedown after yeah such a bad round
yeah yeah that would you did well there
aired in round three he you want it on
all the judges cards and so I feel like
that this fight for me hinged on two
things I felt like that right hand was
huge for [__] of confidence and
everything just went through the roof
and then you've got this it got the
takedown
yeah and it's off send him on the path
of yeah really win the fight but also um
I felt like Conor lacking that sharpness
in the third round that he usually has
to wear when you're on the feet with
them
like and one of the things that
surprised me obviously that's two years
off that will happen but when he just
walked towards could be flat-footed at
the start at the first round me and the
boys are watching the fight and I'm like
he just he doesn't just walk towards any
what what was there a reason for that
he just did want to feel the clinch
eerily mmm you know and we had maybe
slight disagreements on under under
strategy but he didn't want to feel that
am he just like he was going to walk the
dog he's just like haha
go for your takedown let's let's feel
the clinching yeah and he had actually a
great moment in that in the openings of
that takedown exchange you know he
actually ended up on top mhm
and that could be did a great job of
reversing it eventually ending up on top
but it was just it was I don't know
again this is a competitiveness if you
you know the guys great at kicking
alright let's exchange kicks let's see
what let's see if that feels like you're
great at you whenever area greater
that's right come on show me show me so
I think that's what I think that's what
he was easier than a little bit I think
it's just it's almost just like it's
interesting to everybody talks about
let's let's do it let's let's feel it
you know I don't know is easy I don't
know I don't know what it is I think
it's curiosity yeah
this is a really interesting mentality
there because a lot of people's
immediate reaction to anything painful
is I'm gonna avoid that right even
fighters are like I'm gonna try and
employed a punch right whereas Connor
goes the other way and goes let's try it
why is that the truth it's different to
other fighters like I feel like a George
st. Pierre has made a great career out
of putting the fight where he is going
to win it guaranteed almost whereas
Conor as a shoot seems to be let's take
the bull by the horns
yeah maybe not the best way to do it I
don't know what do you change that if
you look at his results he's gotten it's
you know to weight world and to a
champion in Cage Warriors and to a
champion in UFC he's done alright that's
why people love him as well he's alright
he's not a Fighting's a brave spot but
he is one of the in my opinion one of
the brave are guys for taking on the
challenge as he does incredibly
courageous you know I I did joke about
the Diaz fight
the rematch immediately in the locker
room screaming for an Emily did you see
what there's sandier fights out there
yeah you know he's terrifying
individual and can I get your opinion on
one thing that because he broke this
down on Instagram and a lot of people
felt like one of the lines was directly
at about maybe about coaching or I don't
know you can shed some light on it he
said I gave my attacking grappling nor
respect to defense minded lessons listen
to nobody but yourself on your skill set
you are the master of your own universe
I must serve this and I must take my own
advice mmm was that was that about his
game plan or was that just general and
the honest answer is I don't know I
haven't actually spoken about that I'm
really seen him since the fight be
honest I've been just hit the ground
running you know I've got I've got so
much on and he's doing his whiskey tour
of whiskey tour of the world there's
actually solo worldwide it's crazy
anyway am i yeah I don't know you're
gonna ask me to get in the mind of
another human and I can't do it
I guess he said what he said and you'd
have to when get him as ear as your next
guest fingers crossed that you'll have
to ask him you got his phone number I've
got five million does it because
obviously that's not a question we're
trying to draw you out but does it but
bother you from the outside where people
make their assumptions about what
Connors saying and goes if he's having
to go is coach there he's doing this
does that bother you or is that just
like Casper the Friendly Ghost okay yeah
yeah you know we you know we have to
spotlight
Banas somewhat I'm eternally hugely
grateful for the life that Connors
pretty much gave me when it was back and
forward and but part of that is that
we're he's an interesting person people
people want to talk about him and so
again just completely predictable he
puts out a olara a long message like
that of course it's very long message of
course it's going to and I appreciated
his honesty though from breaking it down
because yeah I was actually great for
the fans yeah
mindset buddy normies like that's
usually what I get I got some similar
joke saying after the owl the fight I
got a message like that about what
everything that he did wrong and things
he wants to improve on I was like 11
seconds you know you did you did pretty
well but I thought it was I actually
read that I was like that's cool I'm
actually glad to see people are getting
a little glimpse at the way he very
honest with himself very honest you know
not as arrogant as what everyone seems
to think yeah you know he's so many
great sound bites and he's got that one
about being a confident in preparation
but always humble in victory or defeat I
really like that one and that's how he
is he goes into contests holy 100%
believing he's gonna win like he says
you can you you're gonna feel something
so why not feel like a world champion
and you know with the long with a long
write up like that
I'm just future would you have written
that out to him when he did the bus
incident by golly maybe when you got on
the plane Ireland and then some point in
the middle of that oh like I'm just
watching thing and there's no way John
Kavanagh is on that plane we knew that
you weren't involved in that ring like I
got fired from and I was like I was in
Budapest yeah don't pin that one on me
here ya know no one would have thought
that you'd be like that was the first
thing I thought was what would Jordan
Cavanaugh think of this so what was what
were you thinking when that happened you
know it does I I can't help but be have
admiration for if you know at the end of
that him entire tumor mates the tune
Loucks that our friends and he saw his
friend being if you wanted to use it
here bullied or or whatever way you you
know the videos are there people can
make up their own minds oh I need to
have a mate that goes Roy I got on a
plane and I'll not that he knew what was
gonna happen but just to back up his
friend just to be there for him and yeah
okay look he's we can all be perfect
bastions of morality and sit back on
cloture perils and go home I couldn't do
that book just if you relook at the two
mates and and just going over to make
sure his mate was okay check on his mate
whatever happened happened and I can't
help but be have a little bit of in fact
I'm not gonna
I'd have a lot of admiration to to see
him making sure his friend is okay shout
out to the greatest of all time
autumn LaBeouf they got to go to the
goat one thing that did struck me about
that fight which you're talking about
the actual fight the technique was the
culture clash between the two camps be
two completely different approaches
mm-hmm I'm wondering how because we're
watching on TV I honestly still don't
think you ever get and it's impossible
almost to get the atmosphere inside an
arena through a television was like a
different feeling that night
specifically yeah not really you know I
mean that when you went when I took it
when it's a McGregor fight there's just
a palpable tension in the air when
that's if he's facing Poirier or
holloway or or a beat and so notice
always that walk air and it's always
intense and you know you're looking
around it's just from roads always just
like major stars and
so now I didn't get any real feel from
from the opposing corner actually funny
I was at a fight last night
um at Kean Kelly and happy even his
father were sitting there watching
tonight so that was what was that like
give him a wave no I didn't I didn't I
didn't actually see him but but look you
seen you just clearing at you from the
from this rafters the Eagle ready yeah
I'd like I would like to hope that this
is all just kind of moving on you know I
just don't know at the end of the day
I'm I'm into this for sport I love the
sport teens got little bit our handle
and done and I just want to move on I
just want to move past my mother I'm at
a show every weekend and I want to be
able to look let's build interest in the
fight because that seems to be a way of
making sure about a cleats are well paid
so bill the interesting to fight train
hard step in there give it everything
you have
it's good one hand is gonna be raised
and then have a shake at the handshake
at the end because I almost feel like
fighting like I say if you want to say
pick one organization like the UFC we're
like a traveling circus we go from town
to town it's the same faces at all all
of them the same few comes few coaches
fighters we all need each other
you know or very much so I feel like
that is crystal clear from Connors
career Josie Aldo would never have he
would not be known by so many more
people if he hadn't had the perfect arch
rival in Connor right yeah and so I just
want the kind of that it's done well
I'll do two more questions on the fight
then since because I do want to move on
from that one but did you see the clip
of him saying it's just business in the
cage when they walk they were clinched
against the cage and could we've says
something and Connor says it's only
business did you see that um uh yeah
I've seen I seen except I didn't quite
hear if that's what he said or I haven't
spoken him about it I don't well he
seems that that's Connors man it's just
me you know it's like what what what
would have happened if Connor had a one
do you think he would have evil to just
yeah you know we you saw his wins he
says losses and it's always at the end
like alright well done gratulations and
you know is the could be fight the next
one that you'd won or would you want
someone else I want I want one that has
Connor fired up and if you're deployed
go into my head and say you choose the
next fight it'd be Nate Diaz the trilogy
for the 160 you've thought 500 love it
yeah it's a great fight they they match
up so well I think even just
personality-wise did they match up very
well stylistically it's it's a really
nice fight to watch you know I still
watch that five rounder back every now
and again and the first fight as well it
was enjoyable too and so that's that
that beam that be for me but it would
have to be the one if Connor was to like
burst into the gym in the morning be
like the portray fights back on
you know we're doing a rematch and and I
could see that in him this fire be like
okay great cuz I just love watching
Conor fight mm-hmm I love training him
I'm training with him it's a it's a good
buzz and the lead-up I love watching
they you know I get the best seat in the
house to watch him compete
he's just such nice fluid movement and
when striking Anna's grappling so who is
dance partner is is it's not massively
important to me it's the one that I see
Connor light up because that's it's
almost as biggest challenges now because
it's you know he still enjoy
the negotiation with the USC to get a
few more zeros on a check but it's not
really what's going like what what could
he buy would if he gets another 50
million that he can't bite in he'll like
you know so what was was the motivation
post mayweather money an issue like in
training for i mean obviously he's the
could be bad blood seemed to boil a bit
but was that the same conner
in training for that fight as it was for
Alvarez and hit Diaz was pretty much the
same or was that yeah like the grating
of our say dat fight you know which i
think is one of us best the masters of
all time is if you look at that year we
had you know he had the loss and then he
went insane training for months for Diaz
and then we pretty much come straight
out to that until another couple of
months of tough training and then he
went in again said he just looked I just
started looked fantastic in that and we
didn't have that type of year between
the Floyd you know he's he's guys you
knows whiskey deals bubbling away in the
background he's been at that for years
now he's only broke recently but he's
been out of for years he's putting a lot
of time into dad and you know the kid
and he's yeah order interests in his
life students you're just not gonna be
able to keep up that level of intensity
that we had in the other one now it's
not in any way trying to make an excuse
or anything like that I mean and when
the fight was made he was he was all in
and we trained hard and but you had a
life changes though life changes she was
a son right completely other one on the
way now another one on the way swimmers
are working we can confirm what about so
there's Dylan Dennis who's definitely a
charismatic glad and unbelievab thats
one way to put it unbelievable on the
ground I love how he trolls like I think
he's he's got the potential of a huge
name in the game as well already his
debut he looked great on the ground but
on the feet he did get caught quite
badly a couple of times what was your
assessment of that yeah I mean yeah look
he is is his stand-up is nowhere near
where his his grappling is mhm but is
that that guy was no joke you know is
it's
I could you know Bellator semi list the
names and you could pick
Orthodox guy that's kind of tall and
lanky and you can just get underneath
his hands and get a body like wood this
goes a short squat powerful and oh you
had a hard hit on him it's right sure
yeah the fact that Dylan I think that
punch could have knocked Dylan oh oh
yeah right on the side of dawn like I'm
like it caught him perfect then he's
still awake like yeah so if you want to
say from a coaching point of view you
look at that knee go I'm great you know
this guy could take a shot he's not gone
shy this than you know you're never
quite sure how someone's gonna react to
like a really powerful shot like that
because you don't want to do that in the
gym too often you're gonna be much of a
conversations if you doing that all the
time and so but to see it in the fight
that he took the shot you still come out
the guy put the hands up and went back
in there that's that's shown the right
you know heart and attitude and and he
has that kind of yeah fight in him you
landed a few on khabib to me but because
once you have that then I think the
technical side of fighting is actually
pretty simple but it's very hard to
people are rare that like take a big
shot like that and then still come in
and are still trying to make the
technique work it's a lot easier just to
kind of fall apart you kept this
component he kept his composure so
that's the big takeaway from that fight
for me is either Floyd Mayweather of
boxing no no it's striking is obviously
way behind his grappling and but that it
has to be just functional enough to get
to the stage where you can get a hold of
someone yeah because he's a very unusual
modern-day MMA fighter that he literally
pull guard against pretty much anybody
and haven't happened in seconds later
his grappling is just ridiculous is he
is he on like because to me like popular
drachmas that we seen the passive Demian
Maia right where would you compare him
to people of the past in the UFC what
level am i honest he's arguably the best
and the reason why I say that is because
um like we're all are everybody in the
gym is AK we can't wait for the gunner
Nelson
Dillon Donna's groffle that's gonna have
my cell paper use for that you know
goody Nelson has Guney has just such
beautiful grappling it's just incredible
to watch but it's a very different style
and to Dylan
so Goonies very like controlled get on
top he where he down he feels like a
freaking house has landed on you when
he's on top here Dylan is is much more a
submission heavy just wherever you are
you're fighting out of Annie bard and
you just about got out and you're in an
arm lock and you might just get out a
lady strangling you just such a heavy
submission game that everywhere is just
dangerous with him just can't put your
hand anywhere near so good so young um
again he's got a good story about being
in a local school and in that and Jersey
that's why he's a New Jersey Jersey
thankful anyway and he got really good
there you know was with not many
training partners kind of lower level
training partners but he always was
watching marcelo garcia you know he was
kind of watching him and then eventually
got to the stage where he would and he
was traveling like i think it was like
an hour and a half maybe to get there at
16 or 17 he would get there early do the
session he was broke he had no money you
have to just kind of hang out at a
Starbucks or something then do the
evening session and then get to train
home that nice you know three or four
hours traveling every day for 16 17 year
old and he just did that for years
but such self motivation self motivation
cuz he freaking loved it you didn't need
any rocky speeches he loved it
we've got her a youtuber who's been
calling Dylan out I think you might have
heard of him Jake Paul and he had a box
so much now I really want to play the
footage of the Box much just to get your
opinion these two are both 0 & 0 I'm a
travel well I met air is opponent K
sorry yeah well this is clear sighs
little brother yeah
okay so I didn't fight this guy no so
kiss I fought his older brother it's
confusing
yes annoying this was a cool story Lendl
it work well attacked him yeah pretty
much
oh my god back T so this is that boxing
okay yeah I can stretch it over here
yeah so this is this guy in this white
he wants to box deal and honest he
thinks he can take Dylan after watching
his MMA fight
what what are you seeing you know what
do you thinking after watching Dylan
spar and stuff like that shame II can't
have a great comment track we limit it
you got it
Jorgen watch out that's a joke by the
way before everyone kills me yeah yeah I
mean he looks he's confident on his feet
he's got decent there
he's on every Instagram post that Dylan
when Dylan puts a picture out this kid
joke Paul will comment I would smash you
he doesn't have is that he doesn't have
like huge power and that's the thing if
you're facing Dylan like and that's also
I put them in with that like small
powerful guy just to see how you react
but he I'm facing anybody that's like a
volume striker
it doesn't have real one punch knockout
pair their problem is is that it's gonna
be a clinch so it's unavoidable and then
Dylan has really good takedowns but like
I said easy is a rare breed of modern
day MMA fighter that he could literally
troll guard he could just sit down on
the ground well he wants to box this kid
oh just feeeeel boxing just box
ah okay you're not starting to fight
that that's pure box let's go and box
because actually the wrestler as well
yeah okay yeah a pure boxing I just
think it would be it'd probably be
pretty ugly to find I don't know what by
the pay-per-view in it in terms of MMA I
don't know what the guys grappling is
like but I would bet my house studied be
submitted and lessons without completely
agree I just wanted to put that here
because this is being talked about a lot
on YouTube lately little contest they're
decent this is first ever fight song
yeah we put this on on YouTube did
pretty good numbers considering it's fun
it's interesting with people like Dylan
I often wonder if they have like a
different kind of feel for the body or
like almost like they can feel your
joint so they can feel something
different like because sometimes you
watch him it almost like he's trying to
work out a Rubik's Cube like where he's
gonna right work it yeah and like he's
trying to click something into place and
he knows from that point he's got you do
you do you ever watch someone and just
see this intuition for not being able to
break a bone
but you know being able to twist
something I'm always cautious of like
putting it down to intuition or Talent
if I know the backstory like I said this
backstory is is four or five hours
grappling every day for ten years
yeah that's gonna give you yeah as of
intuition stuff he just it just he's a
very good grappler right he's a very
good grappler hears you you know you the
neck you've two arms two legs he's been
and there's not really any position
you're gonna show him that he hasn't had
hundreds of hours of experience of like
okay when I'm usually in that position
this technique is open and he's just so
good at so many moves whereas sometimes
you may be a role with someone and you
say alright this guy's got really good
leg locks let's just avoid that and then
you're kind of okay with Dylan he's just
so good at everything you know he's got
great arm but arm locks he's got
phenomenal guillotine and leg locks are
just ridiculous you can take the back
he's good on his off his back just a
really top of the steel of Joe Rogan a
really top of the food chain oh my god
ler a black belt who's taps or black
belts yeah just he's really know if
someone who's kind of more drawn to the
grappling aspects of mm8 and then
striking and just suits my personality I
just love watching them move you know
just gorgeous grappling out of other
than your own fighters when you watch
MMA who was it who you probably choose
to watch the most um I always I'm always
excited to see Ronnie yeah and a lighter
a bantam way you see bound to me because
he's a Hickson black belt so we're
always like is he gonna do some Mixon
Sun being signed by Nixon Nixon yeah at
Kron Gracie yeah and I love watching his
fights yeah um you know like Hickson is
over jiu-jitsu guy and you've been doing
it for a decade or two Hickson is
basically you know your superhero
so at any any opportunity you have to
either see him directly or at least
someone who's only one removed someone
like yeah yeah yeah obviously Krone even
more so you can't help but the hair is
New York stand-up and this is I'm not
gonna pick up am I gonna pick up a a new
way of holding the guard or
as he got like you know a way of taking
the back and the royal family on
physically yeah what about John Jones
versus Gustafsson have you got any
thoughts on that that's a big fight
coming that's a huge fight huge fire I'm
very excited about that very excited
because how is John Jones gonna come
back that's a thing it's with
drug-testing yeah but just looking at
that you know from a competitive and
technical point of view it's that those
two are a great match up really good
deals corner of that division I think so
I think so he's it's the only matchup I
can think of for John Jones where year
you genuinely think he's gonna could
lose yeah he was a really good chance he
could lose this in fact I if you were
again gone to my head I would put my
money on Kristofferson to win really
yeah yeah I think a Saracen wins a fight
but the thing is with with John I felt I
mean who knows what was going on behind
closed doors I know he tested positive
for something at the end of the day but
when he didn't test positive since he
shot I came in it was the OSP fight and
he wasn't his best showing Gustafsson so
really good lately as it comes button
cleans out Gustafsson I've just got
given up there I'm like I would agree
with you and I do wonder like because he
was going through the competition so
what appeared to be effort into see they
just grow kind of tired of it was just
like I was hit however however his team
or again I won't say to his coaches or
his team how was he motivating himself
to go to the gym every day and do the
hard rounds do the tough
sparring the tough grappling putting
yourself in tough situations when he was
a when he was apparently able just to
step outside a matrix and just catch
bullets yeah it just feel like the only
way to make him appreciate those amazing
skills that he's just gifted with is to
take the game away from him to be right
play it with them so maybe now we'll
finally get that John Jones like ideas
hopefully yeah and I think partly
because of that because you know he's
back doing what he seems to enjoy and
partly because he's already faced out in
Kristofferson and knows he's no joke
knows he's not able just to run through
him he's he's facing someone who can who
can beat him so is that getting him up
in the morning is he fired up
it's um that's one of my that's when the
fights this year and were you looking
forward to did you enjoy that the second
time around you know a fighter fighting
someone again their kind of fight isn't
it best for me I just think the the fell
teacher and it's always interesting to
see Eddie gonna come in with a similar
game plan or did you change things
around and and it just makes for a
better contest sometimes sounds sounds
kind of silly like but like this is a
wrestlers and when I competed a bit in
wrestling and jiu-jitsu and stuff and
when I was wrestlers you'd say didn't
care they would actually warm up with
somebody new they're gonna compete
because they're like there's no like
secret MIT was like but it sometimes was
make the match a little bit better cuz
you kind of does that awkwardness of
good is gone like there's a bit of a
flow no one's almost gone right yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's a bit of a
fluidity to it I used to actually think
I wonder what to be like if it's two
guys go warm up backstage and then go
out and like I'm sure say you know like
in WWE their ass and their you know they
would kind of practice their moves
backstage so they have that sort of
flowing fluidity when you step in there
and I think I was thinking ever made of
a good thing today yeah
yeah and so in the early over I was
actually warm up next to Conor McGregor
father they were fighting the same night
one right there corrected the Poirier
for damn yeah that was a funny one
do you ever feel under pressure as a
coach to repeat the success with Conor
do you ever like have those worries of
God like honey you find the next guy and
build him up and it's not really a
pressure yourself yeah definitely yeah
like I like if I should actually look up
now under the Lee Hammond wind up when
he did that would be the third reaction
crying
but that'll be the that'll be the fourth
world champion to the trained well tree
amateur and one one professional so
we've had I think decent repeatability
he won't split decision [__] yes
really happy really happy
that's brilliant that's greatness that's
greatness I like that so I know you got
he's got the flag deadly freakin great
that's great yeah he joined in our kids
classes yeah as a I take it 12 or 13 or
something very young kid to see him go
true that come into the teens then come
over into the to the senior senior
classes and he's a tough year so I so
for him to go out there and win that
world title is is huge so that's that's
narrower tour their amateur world
champion and then obviously Connors
professional world champion and so I I'm
I'm happy that we do have repeatability
in our in our em in our training methods
are producing good results because it
will be that way if I just none of my
rest of my team could get a win but I
have this absolute Rockstar a you think
well and you know it's just a one-off it
was it was just a fluke but am you you
want the supposed to I guess people like
Greg Jackson and people like that they
have that reputation right they produce
like war he move yeah they're there
they're the peers I'm I'm chasing I'm
looking after that he just have fun to
obviously have great training methods so
they just seem to have it am when we're
trying to say like a they just produce
some great fighter after great fighter
so I I would working hard to get one
percent of their reputation to do
something so think about Europe to be
fit have already you got any more
questions I thought that I was kind of
wondering about how you cultivate your
own training methods and how you
progress them because I know you're you
know you say watching the fight you're
picking up a little bit you're picking
up a little bit but when you're in it
the daily grind that bubble of always
being around different fighters and
always you know maybe you're in a six
week on it weekend
the campus how do you take your own
methods forward whilst also trying to
take someone else's forward yeah I have
made changes as the years have gone on
and it's a grind sometimes though isn't
it
stick to with this you know that it's
just showing up daily like I said I've
had it's almost comical I I can see the
kid walking into my jam and he's got
he's got like a cheap suit I'm your next
McGregor like you know and it's like oh
okay okay
oh [__] you know loads loads of cheap
suits
no I'm trained I've trained in an MMA
gym before and what I quickly realized
was that I don't want to say this
necessary because there's nothing wrong
with people having dreams but sometimes
you meet dreamers who are never going to
realize those dreams and is it up to you
sometimes to break that reality to them
a little bit and be like how I am it you
know what I mean this isn't this isn't
for you pal and so you know why would
you say that you would say that if the
person so like I've a very again
obviously Connor is the biggest name in
my gym so I can use him when I'm
speaking to a fighter I have a very
clear roadmap now of what you have to do
in order to become very high level so I
can actually show them look you've got
to do this amount of training this is
the routine that hit Conor and I know
other guys who have done well have
followed so follow that roadmap
now they week one they're all in you
know two sessions a day and then you
start seeding and drifting away a bit so
in six months time and I hear them into
gym they're still talking about they're
gonna get that world title I can pull
them aside and say well your your your
actions are not matching your words is
you're saying what you're gonna do but
you're not following the map you're not
following the recipe if you want in
order to achieve the results so that's
fine if you want to just do it out if
you're just a bit of a dreamer but but
I'm telling you that you get that really
you're never going to realize those
dreams because your actions don't match
your your intent doesn't match your your
verbosity Beyonce and so yeah I I will
pull people up now as long as they're
training as long as they're making the
sessions as long as they're I will keep
supporting them because
you never know when a break is gonna
happen and and it's it's a physical
activity that your skills do improve you
keep put yourself into the environment
that I've done my best to create and
I've seen guys that I've gone from being
really really per level to you know
doing very well in a short enough period
of time but yeah it's gonna be daily
training for a 10-year period and then
with a little look and that's something
that you know I've been I've been lucky
enough to work myself into a position
that probably my guys now have a few
opportunities that you know
Conner's generation of fighters in my
gym didn't have because now I do of the
contacts I'm very you know pretty well
respected in Bellator and you see and
I've got good managers and I've got
sponsors and you know I can get my guys
even silly things like known the right
doctors to get medical stone and stuff
like that so I can make kind of those
things happen in the background that
people don't really see I can make those
things happen
a lot easier now than I could have
before so yeah they did a training part
know I'll try make the rest happen as
long as you do that remember do you
think there's something about being
Irish which makes you good fighter not
you specifically but is very racist yeah
a massive racism a huge racist yeah Sam
not really you know like I've got me and
Connor about Irish and we've
night-and-day different personalities
yeah and maybe somebody you know from a
small island that was oppressed and
stuff like that by you [__] yeah so
again you don't really sorry about that
yeah because the first order you know
yet that if you have that kind of
mentality and you're kind of against the
world and as a coach you see that you
said great I'll cultivate that because I
always like I've got fighters that are
super religious and I've got fighters
daughter atheists and I will go to
talking of about God have a half died
there's no levels I won't go to them at
my field that's their little fire you
know I had one fighter and he tells me
what changed to fight at Pedro Cavalli
oh and hey great win here he beat the
bomber world champion in a fight in
England which which won him a huge
contract with Bellator very very happy
with that but going into the final round
was
probably one one there's the last round
and he was really tired he was exhausted
but I also know that he is broke and he
just had a kid and there was one of my
rare times where I did get fired up in
the corner because I felt that that was
the right time to do that and I told him
like that guy over there is trying take
the money oh you're a kid from your kid
trying to take food off and if you don't
win this fight you're not getting the
contract you're gonna be broken not
gonna provide for your kid like I went
out there like a demon some people right
yeah because of again err trusts he's
been with me for a year daily training I
knew Terra
he's a kind of a passionate guy whereas
if he was more like me I feel I'm not
really like I'm more cold and calculated
and that's just my personality I just
don't get fired up I'd be better saying
to him no look watch out for that left
hand you go and move this side when that
left time comes I want you to level
change ago but I didn't borrow Ronnie
that kind of stuff because it was just
there in a bit of a dog fight anyway and
so all the technical stuff and weren't
able to out the window because they were
both tired I just thought I had to tap
into that in that instant it worked with
that fighter it's fascinating isn't it
because one thing that I love about UFC
and I've really picked out from you and
watch you move you know the group of
guys you're a self-admitted casual for
anyone already commenting that in the
car because that's a dirty word and yeah
Mme you can go [__] yourself
whenever gonna meet the point but the
point that that is one thing I love
about the difference in UFC in say
modern-day football or any of those
things is the globalism of it you see in
football this almost homogenous style
now like although Brazilians want to
come to you or appalled the Americans
wanna go everyone wants to come to
Europe to you learn the European way and
what really strikes me about what UFC
has is you've got something from South
America which is completely unique
there's nothing you can fight you know
you you're taking something from
everywhere it seems that must be really
interesting for you to come up against
all these different cultures like with
Connor and Habib that was a culture
clash so I'm saying in and outside the
ring you know it must be such an amazing
especially for a problem-solver like you
challenge every time you get in the ring
absolutely absolutely
even to style a wrestling those guys
bring you know it's different than the
American style of wrestling so yeah it's
a like we said right kind of at the
beginning of this interview dad
it's the constant new challenges that
have kept me like I still feel every day
I go into the gym I still feel like it's
day one I still feel I still get that
same fire if I'm going to corner you
know an amateur making his debut on in a
sports hall down the road I still feel
the same kind of rush on like how was he
gonna do it in Cisco which guy is helps
this guy moving and it never it hasn't
even begun to grow all from yet and I've
always made myself to promise that the
day that comes I would stop coaching
because I think he have to have that
fire in yeah I've seen other coaches get
a bit jaded with it all and and you know
get the stage where just don't really
care anymore and and I just feel at that
stage you've got to be honest with
yourself say okay it's time to try
somebody new so I'm just step back and
I'm not saying I'll never get to the
stage I don't know but beyond I think
you have to be honest with yourself and
do your fighters deserve it that was the
Dare plot in the fall effort in you
should be doing it back you know late
night when you're about to go asleep
awesome because for me my brain comes
away from things when I'm supposed to be
calming down do you ever like yeah
that'll work in this fight does it ever
come to you and like the most annoying
mob oh my my girlfriend will tell you
terrible stories of like literally
waking her up to say could you hold my
hand this way around we've been in
restaurants where I'll make her stand up
from a table and do a single egg on me
and yeah she's she's my my Yuki she's
she's who I is because like you said it
will come in at inopportune times if
it's in the gym it's gray I'm surrounded
by great fighters I can play with stuff
but sometimes you're in a sentiment come
me out let us play with the other
sitting in a restaurant and suddenly he
he gets down on the floor and he's gonna
propose it's funny zarqa she'll see like
I will be doing something you know what
your TV I'll I'll start looking up and
there's got okay okay pause what do you
want me to do yeah and she's quite good
at like you know okay shooter shooter
double on me there and she kind of knows
it yeah happy news net for the last by
very different in the conversations I
have with you
especially shooting on me that's
normally not the context so I've had a
really good chat the dealer has been so
insightful isn't its per million I've
totally enjoyed this you'll really
appreciate you I'm gonna read your book
now I think it chance to read it before
so yes we're not anything
yeah I've got one last question for you
I like to ask people how would you like
to be remembered I feel like I want to
do a David Brent speech you know I don't
want to be tired I just want to see me
and go I must remember to thank you but
you've just gone up in our massive
friend fun it's funny I'm meeting Joe
wicks now later on and we kind of got to
know each other and we met at Easter
there's some Expos and so and then we we
tweaked that we're about insane David
Brent fans so now like our whole that's
all we do every day yes Brent ism's yeah
and a little seeing me like that like
what do you say this time yeah she's not
that big a David Graham fan so we do
Matt we've made careers over that yeah
you're doing that's our job
have you ever thought of when someone
gets into the corner you know it's the
end of the second round in usko so
awkward
what was the do matter that's awkward
isn't it I'd love to see you Scott yeah
alright so how would you like to be
removed if they have to put you on the
spot it's around I'd like to be
remembered as someone who was a good
good coach for mixed martial arts and
that was was technical and help bring
some fighters from beginner level two to
world level and I've been able to help
so my guys set up James and there
they're doing quite well over now so
he'll thought it was helpful to a few
people I like that
I think it's thanks very much really
appreciate it if you want to buy the
book make sure you check the link the
description below
and it's gonna be a win I learned to
write I don't know and I always get a
site is there gonna be in there oral or
what you say audio version of it so I
have to get around to doing at some
stage yeah
no no sorry bad I'll be correct yeah
fired up the whole H exactly be quite
funny
we know learn more thanks for watching
and we'll say is there a Cheers
thank you